Kyle how many filmmakers at Sundance had
publicists and it's a necessary thing
most filmmakers and you had publicists
there um I think everyone in competition
did and probably most of the films next
I mean I think of your playing you have
to know the festival you're playing at
you know I think if you're playing on a
big festering Sundance is the second
arguably the second biggest film
festival in the world if you have an
opportunity to play there like it's find
a way to get a publicist I mean it's
like you know you can get someone you
can find people to work to work you know
relatively cheaply but it's going to
take some money your job of playing at a
fest alone you ask yourself okay you
know what you serve the festival you
provide them content to play what is a
festival provide you well provide you a
platform a for people to get to see your
film but theoretically there's so many
forms of independent distribution and
distribution that let's put that aside
for a second really the festival's
primary purpose for you is the publicity
you get the write-ups you get the
reviews you get all of that and you and
that's your main reason for playing
their cost so much money to get to a
festival so much money to get a film to
a festival at that point the few
thousand dollars plus you know you might
have to set aside to get a good
publicist on board to me comparatively
cost wise seems imperative granted if
you're playing a smaller festival you
know you're playing in a smaller city
without as much press coverage most
small film festivals have a great press
team they usually bring and press teens
from New York or LA and they do the
press for the film's and granted their
their motivation is to publicity for the
festival but they usually can get you
pretty good coverage and it just spends
i would say it depends on how many
movies are really at the festival how
big of a festival is it is it your world
premiere is it you know these are all
the questions you kind of have to ask
because there's a way to do it yourself
um but I also think there's so many
other things you have to focus on
sometimes it's really nice to be able to
have someone worrying about that sign
it's also I find where publicist become
the most useful is they're knowledgeable
about like the critic so then
knowledgeable at variety there's three
critics there let's say or something
then they know they'll say well I think
this one is gonna appreciate your movie
the best because I had this other movie
that was kind of like it and he really
liked it and it really helped us so I'm
gonna make sure he can go like you know
think
that on your own you're trying to get
ready for the festival you're trying to
get materials when you're trying to get
like cast or any travel ready and then
you're going to have to do research on
which critics and then you don't have
the influence to call her ID and say hey
can this guy removing my film not to say
that publicists always have that
influence and I'm just using variety
because it's just broaden easy to
recognize I've never had that experience
specifically with them they've always
been great to me um but it's into my
phones but you know I think it's just
it's someone that can help navigate it
especially if you never have before so I
really strongly encourage it I think of
all festival expenses it's probably one
of the most important to consider but if
you're playing a smaller regional
festival you'll probably be okay because
usually you know you'll have some press
there and mostly local press and they're
gonna want they're gonna want to see key
well you know they're gonna want they're
going to on their end you know they
don't there's maybe 15 movies in the
festival or 20 as opposed to 200 so it's
each situation as its own but it's
definitely something I encourage on the
on the bigger festivals
you